i want to thank the organizers for
giving me this chance to speak
the title of my talk my talk is
therapeutic gene editing enabled by
new delivery vehicles
cas9 based therapeutics have the
potential
to revolutionize the treatment of
genetic diseases
because of their ability to cut dna with
sequence specificity
cas9 based therapeutics are currently
being investigated for the treatment of
a wide variety of diseases
such as cystic fibrosis duchene's
muscular dystrophy
and sickle cell disease however
delivering cast line based however
developing cas9 based therapeutics
is challenging because it requires
delivering
cas9 protein guide rna and
donor dna in vivo and this is
challenging
because cas9 is a large protein it also
has a guide rna associated with it that
needs to be delivered
and frequently not only do you have to
deliver a cas9 protein and guide rna but
you also have to deliver a donor dna
there's therefore great interest in
developing methodologies to deliver
cas9 in vivo and a lot of progress has
been made in this area in the last 10
years
delivery strategies for cas9 can be uh
broken down into two broad areas viral
vectors and non-viral vectors
these both have their own pros and cons
which i will talk about on the next few
slides
viral based cas9 delivery is by far the
most efficient way of delivering cas9 in
vivo
and of the viral based methods uh casino
delivery via
adeno-associated viruses or aav
appears to be the most promising
however virally delivered cas9 has
several potential limitations
the first one is that if you deliver
cas9 via viral vectors
the cas9 will be expressed for a very
long period of time
at least four to five years and this
will cause
a lot of unwanted non-specific dna
damage
because of the continued expression of
cas9 and guide r
in addition the cas9 is a foreign
protein it's a bacterial protein
and if you continue to express it
intracellularly
that will increase the possibility of an
mhc-1 mediated
immune response leading to the
destruction of gene-edited cells
in addition a large fraction of the
human population has
pre-existing immunity to aav and would
be ineligible for an aav based therapy
and finally aav has a fairly small
packaging size limit and if you're
trying to accomplish something like
homology directed dna repair
that requires using two aav delivery
vectors
one for the cas9 and the other for the
guide rna and the donor dna
and this can only be achieved in animal
models if you use
extremely high doses of aav which are
generally far beyond what is clinically
acceptable
there is therefore great interest in
developing non-viral methods for
delivering the cas9
rnp non-viral delivered cast 9 has the
benefit
that the cast 9 being delivered will be
rapidly degraded
within 24 hours after delivery and that
avoids the two major problems associated
with viruses
the because the cas9 is transient the
amount of off-target dna damage should
get dramatically
minimized in addition because the cas9
is transient the possibility of an mhc-1
mediated immune response
also pretty much goes away
um cast 9 has been delivered non-virally
in three different formats aya
either as by a plasmid mrna or as the
protein itself
and a variety of nanoparticle-based
technologies have been developed to do
this
however in general non-viral based cast
iron delivery is orders of magnitude
less efficient
than virally based cas9 delivery and is
therefore great interest in developing
new types of non-viral delivery
strategies
for the cas9 rnp
to address this unmet need our
laboratory has developed a few different
strategies for delivering the cas9 rnp
the first one i'll talk about is a
nanoparticle technology called crispr
gold
crisper gold is schematically shown on
this slide here
and crispr gold is composed of
a gold nanoparticle core that has
a donor dna conjugated to it and
absorbed onto all this
is the cas9 rnp that's schematically
shown here
and in addition to having the cas9 rnp
and the donor dna crispr gold also has
an endosomal disruptive polymer
called psdet which has two different
functions it stimulates endocytosis and
also disrupt endosomes
so crispr gold is designed to deliver
all the components needed for gene
correction by hdr
in particular cas9 guide rna and donor
dna in one nanoparticle
crispr gold has numerous potential
applications
uh the one we focused on originally was
uh using it for treating a disease
called duchene's muscular dystrophy
duchenne's is a genetic disease that has
a frequency of about one in three
thousand five hundred
among caucasian males so it's a fairly
uh common genetic diseases
um it only affects males and there's no
cure for this disease and everybody who
gets this disease
um has a lifespan that only uh goes up
to about the 30s or the 40 so there's a
tremendous
unmet medical need in the case of
duchesne's muscular dystrophy
duchenne's muscular dystrophy is caused
by a mutation in the dystrophin protein
that's schematically shown here
dystrophin is uh
is a protein that is necessary for
muscle tissue to stay healthy
and induce and in patients with dmd this
this protein is mutated
and therefore patients with dmd their
muscle tissue starts to waste away
and that eventually causes death by by
suffocation
now cast iron-based therapeutics have
the potential to treat
duchenne's muscular dystrophy by cutting
the dystrophin gene at the mutation site
and correcting it by a homology directed
dna repair
so we therefore investigated if crispr
gold could do this and we did this in
collaboration with irena convoy's lab
who's also a professor
at uc berkeley and a muscle biologist
so the experiment we did was we made
crispr gold that had cast iron protein
and guide rna and donor dna that was
designed to correct the dystrophin
mutation
and we injected it into mice and
investigated if we could get
hdr in the correction of the dystrophin
gene for these experiments we use the
mdx mouse model the mdx mouse is a
transgenic mouse
that has a c to t mutation in the
dystrophin gene
in exon 21 and this generates a stop
codon so
mdx mice do not make dystrophin similar
to
dmd patients so we made crispr gold
designed to correct this mutation
injected it into mdx mice in their
muscle tissue
isolated the muscle tissue and then did
deep sequencing to see
if we could correct the dystrophin gene
the mutated dystrophin gene back to the
wild type sequence
and we analyze this by deep sequencing
the results are shown here the y-axis is
the hdr efficiency the x-axis
is the various groups and what you can
see is that the mice treated with crispr
gold their muscle tissue
had a five percent uh uh conversion rate
to the wild-type gene so in the dmd mice
that in the mdx mice that were treated
with crispr gold
in the in the vicinity of the injection
five 5.4 percent of the mutated gene had
been corrected back to the wild type
sequence
the control which is the cas9 rnp uh
plus donor dna had essentially
background levels
5 is actually a reasonably good number
uh in the case of
of genetic diseases like duchenne's it's
predicted that would be around where
you would expect to see some clinical
benefits
we also analyzed these mice for the
re-expression of dystrophin
protein via immunohistochemistry so we
injected these mice with crispr gold
made histology slides and stained with a
dystrophin antibody the results are
shown here
uh wild-type mice uh have abundant
dystrophin uh
immunostaining so each one of these
little circles here
is is a muscle fiber that's staining for
dystrophin
the control mice the control mdx mice uh
which have been treated with nothing
have no
evidence of dystrophin as you can see
the blank slide and the crisper gold
treated mice
crisper gold treated mdx mice you see a
lot of dystrophin positivity
in the vicinity of the injection and in
some cases it's as high as 60
of the muscle fiber so we do appear to
be
inducing the re-expression of the
dystrophin protein
one of the benefits of crispr gold is
that it delivers the cas9 protein itself
which should get rapidly degraded after
the editing has occurred
and this should lead to a low amount of
off-target dna damage
so we we measured this by doing deep
sequencing
on uh on mice on mdx mice that had been
treated with crispr gold
where we sequenced six sites in the
genome that had a very high homology to
our guide rna
the results of this deep sequencing is
shown here and you can see that
uh in general our off-target dna damage
is extremely low it's actually below
uh the level of deep sequencing accuracy
so these are all
under one percent the highest one was
point one seven percent which is barely
at the threshold of of uh
of being above background and uh this is
certainly much lower than what you would
see
with virally delivered castling where
generally the off-target dna damage
is in the one to two percent level
finally we investigated if crispr gold
could improve muscle function
in the mdx mass model so in this
experiment we treated mdx mice with
crispr gold designed to correct the
dystrophin mutation
and then we did a four limb hanging test
to see how long the mice could hang
upside down
on a barbed wire mesh and the results
are shown here the y-axis
is the hanging time the x-axis is the
various groups
and what you can see here is that crispr
gold treated mice had a two-fold
increase
in hanging time or muscle function over
the control mice
they're still below the wild type but
this is certainly a trend in the right
direction
so based on these experiments um um
the the lead author of this work uh was
a
was a scientist named lee he was a
graduate student in my lab he formed a
company
uh based on this project called gen edit
he's the ceo of gen edit
and um i don't have any equity in
genetics so i've been so i can
collaborate with gen edit without any
problem and what i'm going to talk about
in the next few slides is a
collaboration that we've been doing
that was done in in partnership with gen
edit
so there are numerous organs where gene
editing can have therapeutic effects
of these the brain is perhaps one of the
most exciting
and this is because neurological
diseases like alzheimer's and
huntington's affect millions of people
every year their incidence is increasing
and there's a great unmet medical need
and new therapeutics are very urgently
needed
in addition developing therapeutics for
neurological diseases
is inherently challenging because of the
formula or movemental barrier of the
blood-brain barrier
and also because uh if you just globally
inhibit neuronal signaling
pathways that results in a lot of
toxicity
we think that localized gene editing
accomplished via an intracranial
injection has tremendous therapeutic
potential
because it overcomes the problem of the
blood-brain barrier
and in addition if you do an
intracranial injection
of gene editing enzymes you will only
edit the region of the tissue where you
inject it and you will thereby spare
the toxic effects of of globally
inhibiting neuronal signaling pathways
and finally because gene editing is
permanent you only have to do this once
and intracranial injections are already
done
in a variety of clinical scenarios
however despite its potential
very little is known about gene editing
in the brain
so we therefore started a collaboration
with jen edit and professor hey young
lee
hey young is a professor at the
university of texas in san antonio
and we investigated if crispr gold could
do gene editing in the brain for these
experiments we use the ai9 mouse model
the ai9 mouse is shown mouse model is
shown here and it's a transgenic mouse
that has the td tomato gene upstream of
a stop coda
so ai9 mice do not normally make the red
fluorescent protein
however because of the stop codon
however if you edit out the stop
sequences
using crispr you can then get the turn
on of red fluorescence
so um gen edit and us we made crispr
gold that was designed to do this
editing
and uh they figured out how to how to
manufacture and ship it and they shipped
it to
the university of texas in san antonio
and hey young then
injected it into the striatum and
hippocampus of ai9
mice and then looked for red
fluorescence and so the results are
shown on the next slide here
so on this slide every every every
little red dot is a cell that has been
that has been cut twice with cast iron
and had a recombination event
that led to uh the elimination of the
stop signal
and then the the the expression of the
td tomato or red fluorescent protein
so you can see in the cast nine case uh
this is this is the
the mice treated with crispr gold with
cas9 you can see a lot of little red
dots
each one of those is an edited cell uh
the control uninjected you don't see any
red
and so this demonstrates that crispr
gold can do gene ending in the brain
for these experiments we also made
crispr gold complex to cpf1 and hey
young injected it in the striatum and
again she saw
a lot of red fluorescence demonstrating
successful editing
hey young was able to get the percentage
of cells that had been edited in the
brain by
doing a simultaneous dappy staining and
then comparing the red
versus the blue so that's what this
looks like here
and was then able to get the percentage
of cell edited edited and what we saw in
both cases with crispr gold and cast
iron and crispr gold with cpf1
is that we're editing around 10 of the
cells and this is actually a fairly
challenging edit to do because for a
cell to be rfp positive
it has to receive two cuts of crispr and
then also recombine
and it turns out the maximum you can get
in this animal model is about 25
so 10 is actually a fairly efficient
amount of editing
based on this hey young investigated if
crispr gold could
edit neurons and for these experiments
she used a transgenic mouse model that
expresses the yfp gene only in neurons
we made crispr gold or c crispr gold
with either cas9 or cpf1 that was
designed to knock out the yfp gene
she injected it into the hippocampus and
then looked for
if there was a decrease in the number of
yfp positive cells
the results are shown here the y-axis is
the percentage of yfp positive cells and
the x-axis
is the control which is untreated or
crispr gold
and i should mention here that to to
make a cell yfp negative all you have to
do is cut it once so this is a much
easier type of edit than the
ai9 mouse model where you have to get
two cuts and also a recombination so
here you just need one cut
and so our efficiency is actually much
higher here so we're get so
wild type is up to about 30 of the cells
in histology slide whereas if you treat
it with crystal
crispr gold this goes down to about 10
so almost a two-thirds reduction
and we saw similar things with cpf1 so
crispr gold can do editing
of neurons and it's fairly efficient at
knocking out genes
so we therefore investigated if we could
have therapeutic effects in treating
brain diseases using crispr gold
the first disease we've looked at is
fragile x-related autism
fragile x-related autism is the most
common hereditary form of autism
and it's a disease caused by a triplet
repeat expansion
in the fmr1 gene and
this causes the inactivation of the fmr1
gene or the fmr1 protein
the fm1 protein is a is an
rna binding protein that acts as a
global inhibitor
of protein expression
and there's currently no effective
treatment for fmr1 related autism
and there's therefore great interest in
developing new therapeutic strategies
now it's also known that in fmr1 uh
related autism
that um um m glue r5
that the m2r5 signaling pathway is over
activated
the mgu r5 signaling pathway is shown on
this slide here and blue r5 is an is
an ion it's an ion channel and it plays
an essential role
in learning and memory and when the m2r5
signaling pathway gets activated
uh that results in a large amount of
protein expression
and the protein expression is an
essential part of mlr5 signaling
now it turns out that in a healthy
patient or in a healthy mouse
when you get mlr5 signaling the fmr1
protein
acts as an inhibitor of acts as an
inhibitor of mgr5 signaling
because it will shut down all the
proteins that are being expressed
due to m2r5 signaling and therefore acts
as a break on angular 5 sigma
however if you have fragile x syndrome
um
which is caused by basically
inactivation of the fmr1 protein
so if you have fragile x syndrome then
you don't have the fmr1 protein and when
you get mlr5 signaling
that signaling goes undamped and is and
and continues to propagate long after it
should
because the f1 protein is not there to
shut down the proteins
uh the protein synthesis induced by mglu
r5 sigma
so there's therefore great interest in
being able to develop inhibitors for
mlr5
and and drug companies have spent a lot
of time trying to do this however this
has been challenging
because uh primarily because of toxicity
problems mdr5
is an essential protein a variety of
other contexts and if you just globally
shut it down there'll be toxicity
and it also has very similar homology to
and also a lot of other ion channels
that have homology to it so it's very
hard to selectively knock out mlr5
in addition the blood-brain barrier is a
challenge
so we therefore investigated if we could
use crispr gold
to knock out m blue r5 in
fmr1 knockout mice and also in wild type
mice and rescue mice from fragile x
related autism
so we made crispr gold that was designed
to do this we shipped it to hey young's
lab
and she injected it into the striatum
and hippocampus
and looked for the numbers of f of of
mlr5
negative cells she did this by
immunohistochemistry
and um and um and the results are shown
here
so the y-axis is the percent of mgr five
positive cells
and the x-axis is the various groups and
uh what you can see here is that both in
the wild-type case
and in the fmr1 knockout case you see
about a 50
reduction in the amount of m2r5 cells
after treatment with push for gold
demonstrating that crispr gold can knock
out ml5 in the brain after
intracranial injection based on this we
investigated
if we could rescue mice from some of the
behavioral phenotypes that are caused
from that that are observed in the fm1
knockout mass
so it turns out that the fm1 knockout
mouse exhibits many of the repetitive
behaviors
that are characteristic of autism uh one
of them
is obsessive burying so if you take the
effort and knockout mice and put them
in a cage with marbles and sand
they will bury all the marbles and
we investigated if knocking out m2r5
could rescue this phenotype
results are shown here the y-axis is the
percentage of marbles buried
x-axis is the various groups so you can
see that in the control fm1 knockout
mice they bury more
more marbles than the wild type mice
and that the amount of marbles that are
buried decreases
if you knock out mlr5 in the stride i'm
using crisper gold
so here you see a lot of marbles and
here all the marbles are buried
in addition we also were able to rescue
against some of the other phenotypes
observed in the fm1 knockout mice one of
them
is is the jumping phenotype so it turns
out that fmr1 knockout mice
jump up and down obsessively that's
shown here this is the amount of jumps
for
in a cage the y axis is the jumps this
is the control
wild type mice and this is the control
fm1 knockout mice you see of almost a
20-fold increase in the amount of jumps
however if you knock out mgu r5 in the
striatum
with crisper gold you get a big
reduction in the in the amount of jumps
i'm now going to switch gears and talk
about some other delivery strategies
that are
that have been developed in the lab and
the first one is focused on
improving the gene editing activity and
delivery of
cpf1 cpf1 is
a fairly recent rna guided endonuclease
that has emerged as a very exciting
alternative or complement to cas9
and so cpf1 what makes it uh
interesting is that it has a different
pam
recognition sequence which is t rich as
opposed to cas9 which has a g-rich
pam sequence and what this means is that
cpf1 can edit regions of the genome that
cas9 cannot in addition
uh cpf1 generates sticky ends when it
cuts dna
and that may lead to better hdr and
certainly could change the outcome of
editing events
after dna repair and especially in
comparison to cas9 which generates
uh blunt ants and finally
cpf1 has a 40 base crrna which is much
smaller than the 100 pace
guide rna of cast iron so make
manufacturing the guide rna in
the case of cpf1 will be much easier now
in the case of cas9 it was known that
that modification and optimization of
the guide rna led to large increases in
the gene editing activity of cas9
however similar optimizations and
chemical modifications of the cpf1 crna
have not been done yet
we therefore investigated if we could
increase the gene editing activity and
delivery of cpf1
by engineering its guide rna and what we
discovered was that if you take the cpf1
crna
and extend it at the five prime end you
can increase its gene editing activity
and delivery into cells
uh in three ways so the first
observation was that if you extend this
the crna at the five prime end uh the
absolute gene editing rate in cells
after electroporation of the rnp is
dramatically increased
and this leads to enhanced gene editing
in addition uh we can increase the serum
stability of the cpf1 crna because the
because the crna extension uh is
amenable to chemical modifications
which can stabilize it against nucleases
whereas the wild type crna is not
and so you can enhance the serum
stability because you can now chemically
modify the five prime end
and finally if you just extend the cpf1
crna
the negative charge density of the rnp
formed
after complexing cpf1 is dramatically
increased
and that leads to more efficient
complexation with cationic delivery
vectors and more efficient delivery in
vivo
so in this experiment we investigated if
we could increase the gene editing
activity of cpf1 by extending the five
prime
end so we so we purchased cpf1 crnas
that had various extensions ranging from
59 to four
base extensions and uh these crnas
targeted the gps the gfp
gene uh we made rnps with them and
electroporated them into gfp hex cells
and then did flow cytometry and got the
percentage
that were gfp negative results are shown
here
this is the wild type crrna no
modification gives you about 20
gives you about 20 to 30 25 to 30
percent gfp minus
and that almost that dramatically
increases almost by twofold so we're now
almost at sixty percent with the various
modifications
so extending it by four nine fifteen and
twenty five all led to dramatic
enhancements
in gene editing in addition we also
investigated if uh these these
extensions
would tolerate chemical modification so
wild type cpf1
is does not tolerate modifications of
the five prime end but
uh if you extend it the extension uh
appears to and this was demonstrated
here
where we took the uh the four and nine
base extensions and we modified the
extensions with omethoxy phosphothio8
and deoxy and then looked to see if we
still saw an enhancement in the gene
editing activity of cpf1
uh the results are shown here the y-axis
is gfp negative cells the x-axis is the
various groups
so this is the wild type at around 25
and again the
the four base extension versus the four
base extension that has methoxy and
phosphothyroids are about the same
and again this is again a two-fold
increase so we can now do chemical
modifications
of the cpf5 primary and we have been
able to show that this leads to enhanced
stability and serum and finally we
we also investigated if we could um
use the extensions to uh to enhance
delivery
so we made the cpf1 rnp with a 59 base
extension so it's not very negatively
charged and
complex as cationic polymers and then we
delivered
this complex into the muscle tissue of
ai9 mice
and then looked for editing so again ai9
mice turn red when
when you when they're gene edited and so
we did an injection of the muscle tissue
and analyzed
six millimeters away from the injection
site and as you can see from these
slides that there is a lot of gene
editing happening
uh up to six millimeters away so we
think that the extension will also
enhance delivery by making it more
negatively charged
in the remaining few minutes i want to
talk about another strategy for
delivering the cas9 rnp
which is focused on making cas9 rnp
peptide conjugates
and uh we think that cas9 rnp peptide
conjugates have a lot of potential
or and certainly some benefits over
nanoparticle based technologies as i
presented earlier
and this is because a cas9 peptide
conjugate is going to be much smaller
it's going to be about 10 to 15
nanometers versus nanoparticles which
are generally hundreds to 200
of nanometers and because of their
smaller size
they should be able to diffuse and edit
tissues that are going to be
inaccessible by nanoparticles
however a major challenge with making
cas9
rnp peptide conjugates is the fact that
if you start chemically modifying the
cast iron rnp you will most likely
uh kill its its nuclease activity so to
overcome this problem uh we came up with
a linker called
trailer which is shown here which is a
disulfide
of linker that allows you to chemically
modify the lysine residues of a protein
but then once it goes inside of a cell
and sees the the
glutathione inside of a cell this
glutathione then triggers
a self-immolation reaction which causes
the release of the unmodified protein
so the chemical uh structure of the
trailer linker is shown here it's
composed of two
disulfide sulfurs an ethyl carbonate
linker and a one six elec a 1 6
elimination
linker connected in series this is the
drug and this is the delivery vector
and once you break this bond you get two
consecutive self-immolation reactions
which leads to rapid and quantitative
release
of the amine and this and if it's a
protein it's going to be the lysine
residue
so we made this reagent here called cpp
trailer which is composed of
uh the cell penetrating peptide arginine
9
connected to a fitzy residue for for uh
for tracking and
also the trailer linker connected to a
paranitro
uh carbamate shown here so that you
could react it with proteins in one step
so we've made cas9 conjugated to this
trailer cpp
and we've investigated what's the
release kinetics uh
after after incubation in 10 millimolar
glutathione
the results are shown here the y-axis is
the cas9 cpp percent
the x-axis is time and you can see that
in in 10 millimolar glutathione the
half-life is about five minutes
this was done by by gel electrophoresis
where we're measuring the fitzy tag
we've also analyzed the um the
nucleus activity of this cas9 cpp
conjugate before and after reduction
the y-axis is nuclease activity the
x-axis is the various groups
cas9-cpp by itself has very low nuclease
activity and this is because
the cpps are randomly conjugated to
lysine residues and will most likely
inhibit
the enzyme function because several of
the lysines are in the active site
however if you reduce cast iron tpp with
gs8 you get
nuclease activity that's essentially
indistinguishable
from the wild type cas9 demonstrating
that we can actually release
active after reduction finally we've
investigated if we could do gene editing
with cas9 cpp
so in this experiment we made cas9 cpp
designed to cut the gfp gene
and incubate it with gfp hex cells and
then measure the amount of gfp
knockout by sanger sequencing the
results are shown here
and the y-axis is editing efficiency
this is the cast nine
this is the cells that have been treated
with cas9 cvp and we're at about five
percent editing and is much higher than
the wild type cast 9 added to cells
which is barely at baseline levels
so in conclusion i've talked about two
different delivery vectors for
transducing the cas9 rnp in vivo the
first one was called crispr gold
and the second one was based off of um
making peptide conjugates with the cas9
rnp
or cpp trailer finally i'd like to thank
the people that did the work
all of the christopher goldwork was done
by one very talented graduate student
named kumuli who's now the ceo of gen
edit the the cpp trailer work
was done by a postdoc named mao maohi
who's shown here
and then i also want to thank all of our
collaborators
were shown here and finally i'd like to
thank you for your attention